4 8 15 16 23 and for the Mega Million
number 42 we all have times in our lives
when we wonder what if what if I booked
this job what if I got everything my
heart desired what if my life were
switched with someone else's would be
leave get off my set you know I'm not
sure how I feel about what else because
on one hand they make me really really
really hate my life what if we could fly
good damn it now my days ruined my
mundane average gravitationally dictated
day but on the other I mean I guess it's
good for your imagination and coming up
with stories and na+ it's like for
what's the point of a what-if even if it
came true it would not live up to your
expectations
so this first video is kind of old it
was posted about two years ago and it's
got four hundred and seventy thousand
views so it starts off with this girl
doing like a vlog or a sketch or
something and then her mom comes in and
interrupts the video what oh by the way
guys wanna throw up on them into trash
bin
make sure it's all the way in the bottom
nuts stuff on the side you know we think
we know where this video is going right
an asian mom busting her daughter for
having sex it gets better
Laurie not having sex it's from my you
should get one too mom
you should get one too I think my
favorite part of the video is this
little hand giggle that the girl does
here yeah I masturbate
I put it over my vibrator so it's easier
to clean I love how open this girl is
with her mom but not only that I love
how cool the Asian mom is with the
masturbation she's like oh okay
vibrators go fuck it literally now
normally I like to end the videos but
sort of like a moral of the story is
because you know I like to put a good
message out there in my work but what if
this video didn't do that bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla rhythm yeah
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh alright thanks for
the tips